Speaker 1: South Carolina. Donald Trump,
after leaving New Hampshire, moved on to
South Carolina to another minuscule campaign
event inside the South Carolina state capital.
It is. It's telling. We're going to witness what
takes place in the coming months with his what
he chooses to do with his rallies. Because for
all of the of the mocking he did of Joe Biden
not being able to fill arenas or whatever. All
the mocking that he's done of Hillary Clinton,
he's now taking that. It's a lot. A lot. It's
along the same lines as when he was making fun of
every politician for reading from a teleprompter
and then shifted and did the exact same thing.
It's okay for him to read from a teleprompter,
but it's absolutely makeable. If someone else
does it. So he went to South Carolina. But
first, actually, let me give you a flavor
for just how small these events are compared to
2016 when he was filling these these rally event
venues just with thousands of people.
This is what he's dealing with now.
Speaker 2: You change the whole system. You need
the president to get to take on the whole system.
And presidents can win it really great this
time. They get 1 million more votes than we
did the time before somebody introduced
me. What was the difference between 2020
and 2016? The difference is we did much
better in 2014. We. Millions of dollars.
But we have to be careful that Election Day.
Speaker 1: And while I was just one to show
you a flavor for the campaign event. Did you
hear what he was saying there, that you need a
president who can take on the whole system? You
need a president who can win, says the loser,
who never got who never won the popular vote one
single time. In fact, this last time when he lost
the election, even the Electoral College with
7 million plus votes he lost by. But he's the
president who can win. It's utter delusion from
Donald Trump. And speaking of utter delusion.
Lindsey Graham. It wouldn't be a South Carolina
campaign event without Lindsey Graham. They're
just hovering, just lap dogging it, just boot
licking. Donald Trump just without shame. With
every time there's Donald Trump and Lindsey
Graham on stage, it is sure to be a dignity
free performance. Watch this from Lindsey Graham.
Speaker 4: Well, he did it once. He can do it
again. And now why we're here. Yeah. So, Mr.
President, I started my political career right
there, and I got my first paycheck, and I said I
got to get out of here to the state house. People,
you're not doing it for the money. There's
one thing I want to talk to you about.
How many how many times have
you heard? We like Trump
policies, but we want somebody new. There are no
Trump policies without Donald Trump. I was there.
Speaker 1: No Trump policies without Donald Trump,
says Lindsey Graham. There's a lot of candidates
actually, who are in the race and coming out of
the woodwork to maybe run for president. We've
got Mike Pompeo kind of circling around writing
his book, getting his name out there. Mike Pence
is reportedly exploring a run. We've got Ron
DeSantis, who's been clamored about in Republican
circles. And Nikki Haley, the former governor of
South Carolina. And on the plane ride to one of
these events, Donald Trump was asked about Ron
DeSantis and Ron DeSantis entering the ring,
about Nikki Haley entering the ring. And in his
warped brain, he believes that because he got Ron
DeSantis elected, it's disloyal of Ron DeSantis
to then run against Donald Trump. And something
similar, he said about Nikki Haley. Watch this.
Speaker 4: Lots to do. Take a listen to
what he said.
Speaker 2: So
Ron would have not been governor because
then what I hear he might run. I consider
that very disloyal to talk to a friend a
little while. But I said, look, you know,
go buy your heart if you want to run. She's
probably said, I would never run against.
My president. He was a great president.
Speaker 1: That's not how it works. Donald
Trump First of all, you didn't get DeSantis
elected. He certainly sucked up the campaign
ads with his baby and with a Make America
Great Again Trump campaign sign. It's all
very incestuous within the Republican Party